the federal judge is temporarily
blocking a gun rights organization from
publishing blueprints for 3d printed
guns a group of eight Democratic state
attorneys general sued to stop Texas
based defense distributed after it
upload and designs for untraceable
plastic firearms the company had legally
published the blueprints last Friday
after reaching a settlement with the US
government in an interview only on CBS
this morning Tony de Coppola met the
founder of defense distributed to found
out why he's fighting to distribute
potentially dangerous information
Tony joins us now this is quite a story
quite a story he's quite an individual
for Cody Wilson this is all very very
simple he believes that everyone in
America has a right to build their own
gun arsenal at home in 2013 he built the
world's first working plastic firearm
and now he's fighting to publish gun
designs online including ar-15 style
rifles and handguns so everyone else can
build them on their own
now we spoke to Wilson hours before that
judge's ruling came down but he was
clear with us he believes he's already
won I believe that I am championing the
Second Amendment in the 21st century I
look at the NRA in other that's good for
the safety of Americans you think that's
good for American families you think
that's good for American streets you
think that's good for America yeah I
think unquestionably it's good for the
future
unquote welcome to Thrusday I think
access to the firearm is a fundamental
human dignity it's a fundamental human
right Cody Wilson's dream of a
downloadable library of gun blueprints
and a world where anyone can easily
manufacture a deadly weapon at home
stalled Tuesday in a Seattle judge
blocked Wilson from publishing new gun
files and questioned whether the Trump
administration should have granted his
company permission in the first place
makes no damn sense no damn sense at all
to make those available Washington
state's Bob Ferguson who led the lawsuit
by eight attorneys general argued that
3d printed plastic weapons are dangerous
because they're untraceable often
undetectable and require no background
check well I'm doing is legally
protected I will go to the appellate
level I will go to Supreme Court I have
a waste all my time Wilson already
published ten blueprints as of last
Friday and the ar-15 schematics alone
have
and downloaded thousands of times there
is nothing good that can come with
defense distributed uploading these
files Pommery is chairwoman of Newtown
Action Alliance a gun control group
created after the massacre at Sandy Hook
Elementary it's a dangerous slippery
slope into our future and our laws and
our policies have to keep up with the
changing advancements in technology the
future is simply digital fabrication
Wilson argues that it's already
impossible to police 3d gun technology
and he believes he has a free speech
right to publish the designs I'm talking
about files I'm not talking about the
guns I'm not a licensed gun manufacturer
I don't make guns at this location I
have data I can share the data when
somebody downloads a gun from your
website with your blueprints and kill
somebody with it how are you going to
feel personally I don't believe that I
provide you anything other than the
general knowledge or what an ar-15 is
but to fund his legal fight Wilson's
company does sell these milling machines
they come pre-loaded with design files
that allow anyone to make their own
ar-15 or 1911 handgun in about two days
no serial number and no screening they
retail for $2,000 and there's a three
month backlog the fence distributed is
still winning this legal battle to be
clear Andy Greenberg is with Wired
magazine and has followed Wilson since
2012 he says in the long run Tuesday's
ruling is insignificant compared to the
agreement Wilson already reached with
the federal government fence distributed
now has the ability to post whatever
files they want and no one has
successfully been able to stop them
permanently from doing that what makes
you comfortable with a world where
people can pump out guns in their garage
anytime they want to what's going to
make me comfortable is when people stop
coming in this office and in acting like
there's a debate about the debate is
over the guns are downloadable the files
are in the public domain you cannot take
them back you can adjust your politics
to this reality you will not ask me to
adjust mine now Cody Wilson says he does
follow all required laws and regulations
and even screens people who are looking
to buy his milling machines under the
court order he can't publish any new
blueprints until September
the earliest now I think they're big
news here is that milling machine it is
essentially a shrunken down gun factory
for your home right the NRA is not
backing him not backing him because he
takes the files and pumps him out at
home no need to go to a gun shop no need
to pay a company no gun gun
manufacturers don't benefit from milling
machines at people's homes he has a
tombstone outside of his office just to
be very clear but what his mission is
and on that tombstone it says American
gun control Wow Tony thanks